[Music]
on today's show we talk about sex and
intimacy a lot so watch out for the
little ears in the room
we talk to a woman whose husband is
transitioning to become a woman
and she fears that her marriage is
finally over
we're going to talk to a young fiance
who's about to get married
and she wants to know if she should
postpone her wedding until her mom gets
out of jail
and we're going to talk to a woman who
has struggled with intimacy her entire
life
and she finally met someone that she
loves and can't get close
stay tuned
hey what up i'm john and this is the dr
john delony show
a live show where we take your calls
we walk alongside you trying to figure
out the next
wobbly crooked step the next right thing
to do
we talk about everything trying to help
people become human beings again
when that when it when we're talking
about what we're eating
who are who we're dancing with who we
love
who loves us dealing with hurts from the
past
whatever it is no matter what's going on
in your heart in your mind in your
family
there are millions of people just like
you with the same challenges the same
struggles the same things
keeping up keeping them up at night
helping them not wake up in the morning
just wanting to hide under the covers
all of it
so give me a call at 844-693-3291
we're going to talk about love we're
going to talk about breakups we're going
to talk about
divorce we're going to talk about what
to do with our pets
i don't even know and we may talk about
this this drives me crazy and i'm
looking for
things that we can do together that are
little things little steps little wins
that are going to help the whole world
be better and here's one of them
you go get some food in a line and
that's a whole other conversation
we eat out way too much but it's the
holidays you're driving around fast
you go get in line and your 10th
your 11th and there's people in front of
you and they're all just standing around
like looking around all over the place
scrolling on their phones
talking and you hear things in front of
you like
oh i'm a cat mom and it's so much harder
than being a regular person mom right
and we've talked about this and you just
want to
set your face on fire to make sure you
can still feel pain
and you're waiting in line and then they
move up
and they move up and it seems that they
seem surprised
when they get to the counter it's like
oh my turn and then they look up at the
giant
16 foot board in front of their face
with all of the food and the prices
and they look stunned wow burgers
french fries no way
we've landed on the moon no way and they
wait in line and they wait in line and
they get right up to the counter and
they seem surprised
that they're going to order food and
they haven't even thought about it yet
so let's do this let's live our lives
with intentionality
and be ready to order when we get to the
line let's use all that time
in line not to look at the at the latest
doom
news not to text
old boyfriends and be like dude what are
you doing bro hey man
hey old girlfriend you still doing vegan
stuff i don't know whatever it is let's
just look at the big giant board ahead
of us
and decide what we're gonna eat and how
much it's gonna cost
and if you wanna if you wanna up at an
annie you can even get your your
payment method out whether you're a
phone waiver and that makes me feel like
we're in harry potter when i see people
do that
or if you're a czech writer like me like
it's the 18th
century i trade tobacco and wheat for
for my food
at the at the grocery store i mean at
the at the restaurants whatever
let's get our payments out let's be
prepared and
let's all make these little changes in
our lives it's going to make the whole
world move a little bit faster
a little bit more joyful a little bit
less less friction
i feel better already 1-844-693-3291 or
go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form and we'll check
it out and see if we can get you on the
show
we are getting hundreds of inquiries
calls maybe thousands maybe millions
it's one of those numbers
and they're coming in from all over the
world it's exciting people are asking
all kinds of great questions great
things great ideas
and so let's look here let's go straight
to the phones we've got let's
go to um let's go to
jane in louisville kentucky jane good
morning how are we doing
hi good morning dr d good how are you
i'm doing so good how are you
i'm doing okay i'm very uh privileged
and lucky to be able to call you
um got a little situation going and
wanted to see
if i can bounce something off you so i'm
just gonna stop you the way you said
got a little situation makes me think
this is going to be a big one
am i right
[Laughter]
it's kind of one of those things where i
uh it's been going on for a few years
but it's
you know i've learned to kind of cope
and it's just kind of getting to the
point where it's all crumbling down to
uh
you know to a dust and uh uh-oh
the house of cards doesn't say it up
anymore let's do this let's get there
so my uh my husband who by the way i've
known since we were 14
but he's actually my second marriage
that's just a little background but he's
actually beginning a transition to being
a woman
okay and um
i feel uh you know it's been it's been
rough
like i'm had to talk to you three years
ago you know i would have
been sounding a lot different but i've
been trying to kind of stick with it and
everything
like maybe hoping it would change or
just
just trying to see if we would be
married as kind of more friends
and i've received advice that probably
wouldn't be healthy
and i i feel that maybe divorce would be
more on the horizon and i'm just feeling
scared and sad and actually paralyzed
about making
a move so therefore i just kind of stay
just stay and and you know i'm not kind
of losing myself i'm kind of
not you know i'm kind of feeling
hopeless and down
a lot and yeah and
so can we do this for a second um i
like transitioning and and
um changing genders all that is big and
it's third rail i want to put that aside
for a second
and just exhale for a second
and let you know this sucks and i hate
that your marriage is crumbling
underneath you
and i hate that you're hurting and
that you're looking at this at the dust
and the smoke and realizing
that you've got some big decisions to
make that you can't put off anymore and
that's just heavy and that's a lot
and so just as you're you're just to the
north of us
there in kentucky just north of us from
nashville and so i just want to look up
and say
sorry i hate this for you and um we'll
dig
we'll we'll see if we can pick shovels
up together and start digging out of
this a little bit
so a couple of questions i want to ask
do you have any kids
uh yeah i have an 11 year old daughter
and um
yeah that's it um but it's not it's from
my first
okay from your first marriage okay and
so what do you want to do
do you want to stay married do you love
this person
um i i love i love him but
i feel that the passion is definitely
gone you know i mean
we we okay we're weird we've been weird
our entire lives like we're
we kind of came together as like
partners in life
okay which which sounds kind of weird
but see he's loved me since we were
in ninth grade okay yeah and after i had
that first marriage which was abusive
and i had sworn off all men and then i
was like
but what about chris because then
you know i thought he's the one person
that would never hurt me
and plus he was missing me his entire
life he prayed
i mean he would literally ask you know
you know just ask all the time to god
for us to get married and i was like
well
and i kind of realized wait maybe maybe
i didn't
ever choose a good man because i didn't
think i deserved it because i was abused
in my childhood and i kind of put two
and two together and i was like
oh maybe i actually rejected him this
whole time because he was good so then
um
we kind of came together as i when i was
i was a single mom and we're you know he
he's been you know
very sweet to my daughter since she was
born and all that because
so you you've just painted me a picture
i want to call this out
you painted me a picture of loyalty you
painted me a picture of
a guy who just wouldn't give up on you
you painted a picture of
he wouldn't give up on you so much that
he was calling in
god he was calling in the cosmos to help
with this deal
he loved your daughter he was good to
her
you had history together but you have
not
once said once the light bulb came on
i was he was it i was doubled over
for this dude and i was in love and love
and love
and i couldn't wait to spend the rest of
my life with him
i couldn't wait to ravish him i couldn't
wait
you're not sending me those signals
you're not using those words and so was
this a
scared single mom who had was
comfortable and had a great friend that
could
she could trust and decided to get
married or did you just fall head over
heels with the dude that had been
standing by you
like every romantic comedy ever right
just by you the whole time
see i know yeah you're you're so
perspicacious
and i really appreciate that i don't
even know what that word means
that was awesome okay continued
that you hit the nail exactly on the
head with the first scenario okay
and and we kind of had this kind of plan
that we would we would get married and
become partners and then love would grow
because
we love each other and and that happened
for like a week
awesome all right so fast forward till
now how long have you all been married
legally um six and a half years
six and a half years and
how long have you not
been intimate together and i'm talking
about intimate sexually i'm talking
about intimate
um spiritually
intimate you tell each other secrets you
tell each other what's in your heart and
minds
how long has that been fading um
we'll see the the emotional this is
really crazy the emotional intimacy is
upped
like a thousand percent because
i was actually the one that helped him
figure out like you know
that that this was going on because he
he kind of you know
was in denial and and all this type of
stuff and i'm like dude you're not in
denial this is like look at what you're
doing this is
and you know and and i was and and i
said you have a wall up
you know i can't get to know you and so
when the wall came down is when
you know when he admitted and he kind of
basically came out of the closet
so at the same time when i got that kind
of devastating news
that he also opened up emotionally so we
tell i tell him everything we're super
close
i mean he's like you know we know each
other
so what's stopping you from so it sounds
like you have an extraordinary friend
a a a world-class best friend
and you love him you would
you know you would to quote the song
you'd stop the world and melt with him
right and he would do the same for you
and your daughter
that that is not the entirety of a
marriage
right that's not the entirety of
romantic love that's not the entirety
of holding somebody and feeling held
and being held so why don't you
go through the divorce what's holding
you back from that
because i'm scared i'm scared of i've
made so many bad decisions in my life
and i'm just scared
that divorcing is another bad decision
um
those are backwards those are backwards
so i want you to set those aside you've
made some bad decisions in your life we
all have
some of us have made bigger ones than
other ones partridge and a pear tree
what about this one you're telling me
that you don't
love somebody sexually you don't love
them intimacy
wise you are great friends you are great
co-pilots but you are not attracted to
him
you don't want to be married to him
through this transition
so what's holding you back
um what are you going to lose um
i guess well
i would say i'm kind of just scared
about the future because
so the future the future jane is on you
in fact the future is on you a couple of
years ago when he started talking about
this
and you knew about this
so the future is on you so it's the
present now what are you gonna do
i yeah i i guess i'm i'm scared about
losing the good things that we do have
because you know we are we are a little
family and
you know there was that potential there
and i'm scared
if you know i mean
at this point i think he won't change so
you know i feel like it probably won't
come back you know the potential for
that
um physical intimacy and stuff
um i don't know i i guess i'm just
i think i'm just kind of mentally broken
down to the point where i can't even
make a decision to
i think that here's what i think i think
you have made the decision
and you don't want to say it out loud
i think you are trying desperately to
not let your world change
and that's a denial of reality because
it has changed
it's changed in significant and major
ways
and i'm not just talking about your
husband's
gender transition i'm talking about
you recognizing oh gosh i never
loved him in this way i never did
i hoped it would get there and it didn't
and
once again i've made a bad decision
i didn't fully understand me i got
connected with somebody that's going to
hurt me in a way
i've hurt myself and so on and so forth
and you've probably heard me talk about
this a lot but
one of the hardest things about divorce
is the actual separation right
the mourning of a failed relationship
or a relationship that didn't live up to
what we all hoped and thought it would
we put a lot
into this we tried hard we were open we
were intimate all that
then there's the the financial side
right you have to sit down and do the
nuts and bolts you have to plan a
funeral for somebody who's still alive
right but the thing that we don't always
talk about
is you alluded to it and we're just
gonna put on the table
the thing we don't often talk about is
that you no longer trust
you you lost
trust in jane you thought this was the
right thing
he called on god to make sure this was
the right one
he was desperate to not acknowledge
who he has come to believe he is
since he was a child he's been praying
to god which is a common thing
i hear that i've heard that for years
and years and years and not only was he
praying to god to change the inside of
him
he was praying to god that you would be
the catalyst for that change
and yes and there's just
a moment when you have to sit down and
drop your shoulders
literally physically drop them and
grieve
it just is and this moment sucks
but the more you try to punt it and push
it and
move it and call it not what it is
the more you're going to continue to
wither on the vine
the more your child is going to wither
on the vine and the more your friendship
and close companionship and community
that you have with this person
that's going to die too because while
you're putting
all your energy and making sure he's
being fully him
and you're making sure your daughter and
i can tell in your voice
you're a killer mom that you would would
like the moon on fire for your baby girl
the person you're not caring for is jane
right yeah because i feel like i could
stay in it because you know he's a good
provider
we have a stable little family going on
and
in that jane that jane is a is a myth
it's a fantasy
it is you do have a stable thing
and if you love this person and want to
stay married and can be
fully connected in a married world
that is incredible
i think i'm i mean i don't think you
would be calling me if that was the case
i think
what you're realizing is that's not
going to be the full answer
yeah because i'm scared i'm scared about
you know
just i i really wanted to get married
also to
show her what a family was like you know
that's right here's what you get to do
here's what you get to do
i i absolutely 100 get that you want to
model to her what a strong
connected woman looks like
what a working mom what a
connected mom who loves her daughter
looks like what a devoted wife looks
like you you want to do those things
and now what you get to do which i think
is a
undervalued modeling exercise a modeling
moment it's not an exercise
you're in it is you get to show
your daughter what a good
woman who is struggling and grieving
looks like
you get to teach your daughter how to
love well how to grieve well
how to be open and honest
and you get to show her what little wins
looks like taking care of yourself even
when you're hurting
what going to a counselor looks like you
get to model
all that for her and over the course of
her life
that would be one of the greatest gifts
you can give her
because here's what it's look like when
bad things happen because all of our
kids are going to get punched in the
mouth at some point in life
and you get to model that for her and
that will be such a gift
so practically speaking practically
speaking
i'm gonna have james put this in the
show notes i actually just wrote an
article
for dave ramsey.com about divorce
and divorce sucks and it's just a
divorce checklist here's some things to
to think through as you go through this
and if it's amicable if you've got two
people acting like adults
and that's there's one way to do it and
then if you've got one person throwing a
temper tantrum the other person trying
to act like adult there's another way
but we're gonna link that in the show
notes and we're gonna
make sure that you get a copy of that
okay
the second thing is this here's the just
the practical practical sense of this
number one and i'm i'm repeating myself
here but i'll make sure you get this
there is a practical money side kid side
to this
okay your daughter will need your direct
attention
your direct honesty right
um straight talks you will need love
love love and that will look like a lot
of physical touch from you
that will look like a lot of physical
touch from the person she knows as her
dad
that will take a lot of honesty and i
love as my friend rachel cruz says
share don't scare be age appropriate
right be age appropriate and don't be
overly gratuitous and don't be overly
graphic be
um but be honest kids can
feel that gap when they're being lied to
they can feel that gap
of disconnection and they blame
themselves and try to fix it
don't don't put your daughter through
that be honest
be it be straight up with the money this
may mean you have to go back to work
this may mean you have to get a
different job as you said you've got
this secure little unit and it's secure
for the moment but it's
not it's not
it's got a shelf life to it and you know
that and you've got some time
before this thing finishes itself out
you got some time to make some plans
the second thing is is grieving your
life is changing
someone you love i was gonna say through
a grenade but not really
so when you love was honest with you you
were honest back to them
and then here we are right and so i
wouldn't even call that a grenade
but your life changed in drastic ways
and i'm gonna even go back and say you
knew going in
this was a hope and a prayer you were
hoping
that you would fall physically attracted
to this person you were hoping
that your hints and thoughts over the
years
would go away you thought that if
somebody loved you enough that you would
eventually come around and love them
you've got to grieve that this is a big
loss and you've got to grieve
once again your loss of trust in jane
and i think jane's got some really
extraordinary intuition
and jane you have got to go see a
professional counselor you talk about
childhood abuse you talked about an
abusive relationship
the person you need to invest in right
now besides your daughter is
you go talk to a professional and unwind
some of that stuff from
your childhood my guess is you've got
extraordinary intuition
you have one of the best gut feelings of
anyone you know in your world
and you have an extraordinary ability to
squash your gut feelings
put them in a closet shut the door lock
that door and then go do
what other people in your life want you
to do which is classic behavior of
someone who's been abused as a kid
and then the third thing is you've got
to decide
what you want
not somebody who has been in love with
you since they were 14
not somebody who's transitioning to a
new gender not somebody who tells you
well you know what you need to be doing
for your kid
not somebody who fill in the blank you
need to
take some time you probably need to do
this with your counselor this isn't
forever
you don't need a counselor forever but
you do need one for a season
you've got to ask yourself what do
you want
you hint it a little bit in this
marriage you have to be all
in and they do too
your transitioning husband has to be all
into
and 99.9 of my gut feeling is you're out
you just can't say it out loud
what do you want to do professionally
what do you want to do
emotionally and relationally what do you
want to do as a mom
you've got to articulate those things
jane this sucks and again everybody i
know it's big and it's
it's um all around the bend this is a
woman with a broken heart
who once again is looking in the mirror
and saying gene you dummy you made a
stupid decision again and jane my
heart's broken for you
you didn't make a stupid decision you're
a good human being your extraordinary
mother you're
been a great wife and it's time to be
honest with
yourself and what tomorrow tomorrow's
gonna bring stop living in the past and
let's move to the future
thank you so much for that call jane all
right let's go to kristin in oklahoma
city kristin what is up
hi john how are you so good how are you
good so far better than a lot of people
all right all right so
how can i help i need some help walking
through
a little issue i'm having i am getting
married april 11th
next year um and my mom is in prison
she's been in prison
for a little over a year now
um she's been in and out of prison my
entire not really prison this is her
second time being in prison but she's
been in and out of jail my entire life
um we were super lucky my grandma took
my sister and i in and raised us from
when we were like
three um mom's not really been a great
mom but she
uh i mean she's my mom i love her i want
her to be at my wedding
um she has been doing really great
this time around i think she's finally
kind of figuring out that this is either
gonna kill her or
she will you know kind of grow up
um but i see i'm getting
married on the 11th and if she when she
finishes this program
she will maybe be released
um on the 5th of april so we're not sure
if i should push back the wedding so i
know that she will be out
it kind of just depends on who's in a
good mood and who's not
um or if we should leave the wedding as
it is and if she's there
she's there and if she's not she's not
um so
kristen how many times have you planned
things in your life
and mom didn't show up everything
everything yeah how many times
have you opened your heart yet again to
have your heart broken
forever forever all right so nobody
i i don't know anybody in my circle that
believes in redemption more than i do
i don't know anybody in my circle of
friends in community
that goes on the regular basis says
let's give that person one more shot one
more chance i'm that guy
okay yeah
but you've got to let the fantasy go
yeah
and you are still hoping and dreaming
and putting your heart
back out there again that this is going
to be the time this is going to be the
time
i think you should go ahead and have
your wedding you should plan your
wedding if your mom is out that will be
great and a bonus
and if she is reformed and healthy and
lovely and wonderful that is so good
so good but she's probably not going to
be
yeah i thought you'd say that
and i don't want you to set yourself up
this really important benchmark moment
this moment when you are joining futures
with somebody else i don't want you to
hinge that
on a myth on a fantasy right okay
this relationship with your mom can heal
and it can take
years and years and years and years to
heal
and it's going to start with little
breakfasts and it's going to start with
getting together once a month it's going
to start rebuilding trust
that trust is hers to build not yours it
doesn't mean you don't love her doesn't
mean you're not connected with her
but it does mean that this time your
grandparents are there
this time your awesome fiance your
husband's going to be there
move forward with the date if she makes
it great if she doesn't
great and
i hate saying that out loud now because
i'm just sitting here saying it i hate
it
because i believe so strongly in
honoring our father and mother i believe
so strongly in
honoring wisdom of people who are older
than us and have more experience than us
but i also know that parents just they
cash in their parent card
they're abusive they are addicts they've
got their own demons that they wrestle
with
and they push their kids aside as they
deal with those things
they break the law they end up in jail
over and over and over and over again
and at the end of the day we can love
them we can honor them we can be
respectful for them
and we can also go and continue to live
our lives
and there's a tension there and it's not
one and it's not the other
but there's a tension there
so you got to hold them both and right
now kristen i want you to plan your
wedding
once you've got a date everyone's going
to be there if your mom's there it'll be
one of those fairytale things that'll
make for a good video
and if she's not you're not going to get
your heart broken again you're not going
to move everything around just for her
so thank you so much for that call go
get them and hey when your mom gets out
call me
when your mom gets out call me both of
you all call me kristen i want to hear i
want to celebrate her
and hopefully she gets done and makes
that wedding that'll be awesome all
right let's go to april at state
in state college pennsylvania april
what's going on
hi john thanks so much for taking my
call thank you for calling how can i
help
well so i've been in a relationship
since may with a
really wonderful guy who treats me well
and who has a lot of the qualities i
desire and a partner
but i just don't feel like i'm starting
to fall in love with him yet
and it's almost like when he tries to
get closer
i feel the urge to start to pull away
and i guess that just scares me because
looking back on
past relationships like i realized that
every time that i've been in love
it's always been what's a really
unhealthy partner
and when i find a man who would be
suitable for me it's almost like i
have a tendency to either put him in the
friend zone or i just can't develop
feelings for him and i just don't know
how to fix this
sure so a couple of quick questions in
do you have any relational abuse in the
past
or just guys that cheat on you do you
have guys that are have been awful or
ugly
you have childhood abuse like give me a
quick primer
um so for example my last relationship
um the person
had a problem with alcohol and really
only wanted to see me when he was
drinking
and he ended up cheating on me while we
were
dating but as far as my childhood
my older brother has cerebral palsy and
so my
past wasn't abusive it was just my
parents really didn't notice me because
they were
really focused on my brother and his
needs for most of my life and so i was
always just very
like self-sufficient and was
trying to meet my own needs sure very
much so understand this
trauma works two ways one is
what i would call affirmative trauma
someone's alcoholic
they're abusive to you they hit you they
yell you see a car wreck you see
somebody get
shot those are affirmative traumas
there's also neglect traumas
where people don't give you what you
should have had
which is connection and value and high
touch
and daddy's looking at their daughters
on a regular basis
in the eye and saying how are you tell
me about your dragons tell me about your
princesses tell me about your baseball
hugging their sons right that's those
are both traumas and your brain
registers both of those as there is a
problem in a relationship that is my
fault and i've got to fix it
it also logs in and i hate using
computer metaphors as you know i can
come up with on top of my head right now
it begins to log in relationships
hurt there is pain here
and it's begin scanning your environment
for the rest of your life for somebody
that's going to hurt you
and so two things emerge from that sort
of
um from that childhood number one
other people are more important than you
and it's your job to make sure you plug
into others
and number two people hurt and so when
somebody who is
good and somebody who is right and
somebody who is noble
tries to plug into you your brain sounds
the alarms
it goes off danger danger will robinson
look out
run right yes exactly
and so you think you're only worth an
alcoholic idiot
and that's a lie and now you're looking
at this other dude
do you do you find him attractive would
you love to just
smooch him and smooth like so what
happens you lean in to give him a kiss
what happens
i just feel really uncomfortable i think
with any sort of like physical closeness
or if he wants to spend a lot of time
together it's almost like
i just i just want to pull away for some
reason so is he annoying or is this on
you is he unattractive
does he not shave does he not brush his
teeth or is this
go ahead yeah he's very attractive and
honestly he has like all the qualities
that i would want in a future husband
like i could see a future with him
it's just the the feelings aren't there
yet i guess
i don't understand what you mean when
you say the feelings aren't there yet
what does that mean
just the feeling of like in loveness and
that spark and like wanting to be with
him all the time like when i
hang out with him it's almost like it's
a chore that i have to do to let someone
else into my life
and it's almost like i'm more
comfortable just like being alone there
you go
and is that a learned behavior is that
something you've experienced your whole
life
i mean you talked about when you were a
kid you had to be self-sufficient from a
young age
yeah yeah i moved out when i was 17 and
pretty much been on my own since
have you ever been in love this spark
that you're craving or are you
watching hollywood videos and wanting
that
no i was in love with the previous guy
who
had the problem with alcohol and i think
it may have been
because he needed me and it kind of gave
me like a sense of worth
there you go so what you're gonna have
to do is you're gonna have to
come to the realization that you are
worth being loved
not you are only have value when you fix
other people you only have value when
you make sure everyone else is okay
but that you have value just because and
somebody else
has the right to love you the way that
you want to love other people
and the the
the the broad picture here is the fear
of intimacy
right it's this fear of getting close to
somebody because they're going to hurt
me
that i have no value that i'm not worth
it right so here's a couple of things i
can i can tell you
um you've got to ask yourself do you
want to love him
and so this big clouds and rainbows and
marshmallows all of that the lightning
bolts and all that
it doesn't happen for everybody and it
happens differently for other people
and i know hollywood so bad wants us to
believe that's the way it works it
doesn't always work that way some people
it does
and they are lucky and they are blessed
and that's awesome
um in my house it happened that way for
my wife and not for me
she she'll tell you i looked at you i
was playing a i was singing a song at
some
show and she said that's the guy that's
it
and she was done like literally done
and it took me years to
um recognize oh she's the one for me
right she is the one i want to dedicate
my entire life to it works
different for people and so you i want
you to look
look at at moving forward this way
not as love as a lightning bolt love is
a quote unquote feeling
but that love is going to become a skill
love
and intimacy are going to become skills
that you need to learn
okay um things you're going to have to
practice and things you have to be
vulnerable
vulnerable about with other people okay
there's a couple of great books out
there i'll recommend one of them here
let's talk for a second just globally
and this isn't just for april this is to
everybody
i want to talk for a second about this
idea this fear of intimacy
okay fear of intimacy it's a broad
psychological term that describes people
who are afraid of being in close
relationships
and this can be a challenge even in
long-term relationships just because
you've been married a long time
having regular sex have a few kids
doesn't mean there's
not major intimacy issues and we often
think intimacy is just about sex it's
just about holding hands and kissing
not all intimacy is sexual it can also
be emotional
spiritual intellectual experiential
right
we have the same interest we have the
same experiences
right it's this idea of intimacy is
being fully
known can i be completely honest about
the thoughts in my head
can i be completely honest about
my actions what i've done
and here's where it gets even deeper can
i be completely honest about what has
happened
to me can i talk about my hurts right
so can i talk about what's in my head my
thoughts and my feelings can i just put
them out there without being judged
without me giving without being given
advice can i talk about the things i've
done
here's some stupid stuff i said when i
was in high school here's somebody i
hooked up with when i was in college
here's somebody fill in the blank can i
talk about the things i did at work that
i wish i hadn't done
whatever it happens to be do i have a
safe place where i can come home and put
that down
and can i talk about people who've hurt
me
and if you're listening to this and you
know what i'm talking about it feels
like
doors just one door and then another
layer and then another layer
right being afraid of intimacy doesn't
mean you don't want to be intimate just
like
april just like you're saying it doesn't
mean you don't want it
it just it might look like indifference
coldness or anger
but the person who fears intimacy
usually
desperately longs for it and you've
heard me talk over and over and over
about intimacy loneliness a lack of
intimacy and loneliness
are killing us as a country killing us
individually it's destroying our bodies
because our bodies crave connection
right a couple of causes of fear of
intimacy
comes from being hurt by others it's
complex but it stems from
attachment issues it can come from
unstable unpredictable childhoods
think think of this line and tattoo it
on your heart childhood biology
becomes our adult biography a few
situations as we talked about with april
um parent illness brother and sister
illness
right it's this loss of innocence at a
young age before you understand fully
what's going on
parent neglect abuse parent substance
abuse
loss of a parent codependency enmeshed
families unresolved
grief here's the deal in april this is
specific for you but it's also for
everybody
relationships equal risk always
relationships are a risk i don't care if
you've been married for 30 years
if you've got secrets you haven't told
you know it's because it's a risk
and you're afraid that that person's
going to hurt you they're going to
weaponize what your secrets are
you're afraid that they're going to tell
you oh yeah well you should just
fill in the blank as though you're an
idiot
relationship is a risk and when you've
seen the other side of risk
your brain and your body try to protect
you from getting hurt again
right so here's how to overcome the fear
of intimacy number one april here's what
i want you to do
whenever that guy this beautiful guy who
treats you well he's a good person
whenever he leans over to hold your hand
and you're you're like ah
try this thank your brain for trying to
protect you it's just doing its job
i want you to exhale i want you to say
thank you but i'm good now this guy's
safe
thank your shortness of breath think
your heart rate
thank your body for protecting you if
you have a fear of intimacy and you know
you are safe
and you want to get close to somebody
think your physical response
and then i want you to decide what you
really want
you cannot have meaningful and deep
relationships without
intimacy without being able to say
here's what i'm thinking here's what
i've thought here's what i've done
here's who hurt me and you can't be
intimate if you can't receive that from
other people
accept that intimacy equals risk and
understand the rewards of intimacy are
so worth it
and you're going to get hurt in
relationships you just
are i want you to embrace vulnerability
and own the risk
being close with people is scary because
it involves vulnerability and
vulnerability is when you expose
yourself to the possibility of being
hurt
and if you love somebody you will be
hurt period at the end of that sentence
exclamation point at the end of that
sentence you'll be hurt
you can read daring greatly by brene
brown if you want to really get into
sexuality and intimacy you can read a
book called come as you are by emily
nagoski
it's probably the best book i've ever
read on sex it's not a faith-based book
it is a science book written for dumb
people like me
she does a great job of just distilling
things down in a very simple way
but she talks a lot about this falseness
of sex being a drive and intimacy being
something other than something you learn
and you practice
and then go for little wins exposure
they call it in the psychology
world try holding hands try being honest
ask for patience try writing letters or
gently leaning in
let intimacy come through letter writing
where there's a little bit of distance
not through text messages
but through letter writing where there's
some distance some space
but you're being vulnerable you're
beginning to expose your thoughts right
when your physical alarms know off know
that you're not gonna die
you're gonna be okay and your feelings
are okay
they're just trying to protect you and
then also
if you really have problems connecting
with other people
you know you've got to go see a mental
health professional if you have a
pattern of a fear of intimacy if you've
got deep-rooted things
april you're telling me this stuff's
been around since my childhood you may
need to get with somebody who will hold
you accountable with a professional a
mental health professional hold you
accountable give you some things to try
and practice
this is not a forever relationship you
are going to learn some new skills
it's like getting a batting coach except
you're going to get an intimacy coach or
a love coach or a relationship coach
right
make an appointment to talk with a
therapist or counselor listen to me
april and to everyone struggling with
intimacy
men women beautiful people people who
don't believe they're beautiful
everybody you are worth
a relationship you're worth being
connected
you're worth being loved you're worth
all of it
all of it okay you're worth all of it
and so i wanna
sorry i leaned over here i want to i'm
just gonna do one song but i'm doing
another one
and i love it and it kind of applies
kind of dozen as i wrap up the show here
this literally is one of the greatest
songs of all time and it's classic
because a
husband stole this song from his wife
but the song was so great i say stole
maybe borrowed
maybe it was lent i don't know but he
got credit for it even though she wrote
it
from the 1963 classic
from nashville's very own johnny cash
the song is a ring of fire and it goes
like this
love is a burning thing and it makes a
fiery ring
bound by wild desire i fell into a ring
of fire
love hurts in its risk i fell into a
burning ring of fire i went down down
down and the flames went higher
the taste of love is sweet when hearts
like ours meet i fell for you like a
child
ah but the fire went wild i fell into a
burning ring of fire i went down down
down and the flames went higher
and it burns burns the ring of fire
that ring of fire this is the dr john
dolone show